54 years old have had herpes for 32 years. Now constant outbreaks. In fact, 43 outbreaks
since January 1st of this year. If I eat most any carbs, even fruit, it can break me out.
Of course, foods high in arginate, nuts, and seeds, and grades can just eat one or two nuts
that break out, so I avoid them as much as possible, but sometimes I crave them. I have done everything
big abandonment. Early on, I tried Zomeric and had terrible side effects. Since then, I've done
lysate peroxide, monolore, and oregano, and something that parasite cleanses long-term,
consistent red heat lamp sonar, castor oil packs, coffee, and a most grayed retray, full-time
gene, high frequencies, and on and on of adduro slams, which diagnosed with MCAS two years ago,
and which I have uncovered mold, lime, strep, hamsteen bar, along with this. I've worked
on gut liver, got root canals, taken out, new David, just can't imagine how to break the code.
I know I am missing some lams that may help me. Any suggestions?
Well, there's no way I can uncover that ball of wax on a platform like this, so we need to dig in.
I mean, if you really want me to help you, you're going to have to make a case, do a case reveal,
and we're going to have to get going on a plan of attack of some different investigation.
So what a person is hyper-sensitive to anything that causes a flare somewhere else in their body.
So in this case, it's causing a herpes flare. Herpes is a virus that lives in the nerve ganglion.
So, for instance, like herpes in your mouth, it lives in the trigeminal nerve ganglion.
That's a ganglion of nerves right up here from cranial nerve 5. And then that will come out
in your mouth when there's an opportunistic time. Usually with herpes in the mouth, it has to do with
pH change your mouth. You suck on a lemon and you get a colesor, kind of often people end up with that.
So it's because that drastically changed the pH of the mouth and the
immune response went down and the virus just vibrated right down the nerve pathway
and erupted in the lip or wherever. Same thing with genital herpes, it's a virus that you really
and a lot of these viruses you can never kill them. You can't kill them. There's no immune
magic. There's no right frequencies that can completely kill them because there's debate whether
they're leaving even living organisms, right? So there you have to learn how to manage them.
So with management of that, you're going to find the different triggers. So you think, well,
it's that food, that's the trigger. That's the trigger. Well, even if you know, okay, it's not
food that triggers it, it can be an underlining core trigger. So it's some inflammation that's going on
in the gut that is that you're at this hyper response, meaning that you're right below threshold. So
anything is just constantly just tipping you over. So you have to figure out what are some other
core triggers that are keeping your immune system at that hyper response just below threshold.
So I'm not always getting an outbreak, but then anything just sets me off. Anything just tips me over.
So you've got to figure those things out and clean those things out. It can be complicated.
It is a mess and I understand it is extremely frustrating. But you can't give up on yourself. You just
gotta keep taking it.